They say that life is better here in the Philippines,...
...and on Boracay, it's certainly easy to see why.
We have amazing resorts, fantastic food,...
...and some of the friendliest people you'll find anywhere.
Mabuhay!
But why show you that when I can show you this.
Along the white beach of Boracay, you'll find hundreds of tour operators.
Picking one or the other really doesn't matter...
...since they essentially take you to the same place.
Today, Jo and I hopped aboard a speedboat,...
...and before we knew it, we were hoisted up into the air,...
...soaring above the sea more than 100 feet,...
...taking in Boracay's spectacular views.
Our next adventure also had us harnessed in...
...as we soar through the treetops on a fantastic zip line.
But by far one of the most memorable experiences we had was at zorb park.
Imagine being placed inside a giant rubber ball and then being pushed down the hill.
That's exactly what you'll find here.
Now, there are two options: the dry and the wet.
And for my money, the most fun you can have is inside the wet zorb ball.
As a tropical paradise, Boracay has some amazing dives.
Dive gurus on station number three operates about five dives per day.
If you don't have any gear, don't worry.
They can rent it out to you for very cheap.
If you're not a certified diver, they also have classes running at your convenience...
Where you can become a certified scuba diver in as little as three days.
The diving is fantastic,...
...allowing you to get close to corals and fish.
So there you have it.
Some awesome activities here in Boracay.
Thank you very much for watching.
I'll see you next time.